you think there are similarities between
the Pink Panthers raid and what happened
in London over Easter weekend what are
those similarities yeah I mean there are
definitely things that are required for
an amazingly successful diamond heist
the incredible planning this must have
been planned for a very very long time
and some of the people that I met and
spoke to from the Pink Panthers they
would you know they would spend up to a
year or more casing one particular joint
getting everything prepared recruiting
their team and finding an insider
basically to help you they hope you
don't know who were the Pink Panthers so
the Pink Panthers are a sort of loose
network of gang members who essentially
they just slightly that their
traditional robbery is slightly
different from base they do tend to do
smash and grabs from kind of high-end
diamond stores but what will be similar
is the route that the Diamonds take once
they're out of those safety deposit
boxes so they will be passed to a career
within hours The Courier has to get out
of the country or across a border very
very quickly and then those diamonds
will be taken to a buyer somewhere that
will probably be pre organized and often
to order but the hole is estimated to be
around 200 million pounds I mean it's
one thing to steal diamonds and precious
items it's another to try to sell them
on where do they go how do they try and
sell them yeah I mean that's the that's
the crucial thing I mean this this
obviously is a raid that is incredibly
sophisticated and there's taken a huge
amount of time but you could do all of
that and still be left with diamonds you
can't sell so you have to have certain
contacts or fences who will clean the
diamonds or at least get them into a
state that they can get onto the black
market so a really big valuable diamond
will probably be recut you will have its
documents forged and it will be put back
into the
the legal market and a dealer will sell
to a deal it'll sell to a dealer and by
the time you and I are lucky enough to
get them and we have no idea that it was
one of the stolen ones originally but if
they're small they probably kept on the
black market and they become currency
for a much wider and a much more
sinister kind of crime Network so you
want to buy drugs you one of my arms you
want to buy people you will very often
pain in diamonds bad news for those
people who are watching who have had
their belongings stolen from this book I
mean some of them don't even know yet in
fact most of them don't even know yet
and is there any likelihood that they'll
get their possessions back or are they
gonna just have to write them off as she
said it's such a sophisticated operation
long time in the planning execution they
seem to have had four days over the
Easter weekend to carry it out amazingly
they had such a long time to do whatever
they wanted really um actually if you
had a really special diamond I mean no
diamond is I mean every diamond is
unique and if you had one that is really
special they're us and it had been
graded and it had gone through all the
legal channels or the official channels
then there are chances that it could be
found and that has happened before you
know something robbed in in Dubai can be
found in the markets in New York and be
identified on return so that has
happened most of the smaller ones most
of the kind of bulk and probably just
going to get get lost in the system okay
have had a marking let's hope that most
these people were insured I'm sure
there's some items there that they'll
see it will be deemed to be
irreplaceable to people okay interesting
to hear for me thank you